dave when you were on saturday night
live jagger was the host
did you get the hang with him at all
yeah
was he a good guy yeah
what do you mean yeah he was funny he
was funny
he was really funny and the funny thing
was like okay so
he was going to host it was the season
finale and he was going to host the show
but stones weren't doing anything and so
i actually got the call from lauren
and he's like uh mick jagger's going to
host the show but at the stones
we were wondering if you could be the
backing band i was like oh [ __ ]
absolutely
yeah and so i [ __ ] i'm like i'm like
when is it he's like may 18th or
whatever so i'm like cool i open up my
laptop and i see may 18th
was like a show at like jones beach or
something like that new jersey
in jersey and i'm like oh [ __ ] uh
well okay so i uh we got a show that
night but i'll get rid of it and we'll
[ __ ] because
dude we get the jam jagger and i call i
call our manager john silva and i'm like
uh
john uh we just got asked to be jagger's
backing ban on snl so we gotta lose that
show he's like
it's they've already they already sent
the check you can't [ __ ] do it i'm
like okay
so i guess we sound checked jumped on a
helicopter
did the gig helicoptered back to the
city jammed with
mick and then afterwards played the
season finale party
in that little square where they got the
ice rink and all that [ __ ] we played for
another two hours we did cover songs
and he actually jumped on stage with us
and did cover songs with this is amazing
howard he he showed up the first because
when you do snl
you have to rehearse at like 10 in the
morning
and he comes in it's i was up i was i
didn't really sleep much so i'm just
barely gonna
sing or anything i'm not gonna do much
i'm just gonna and we start playing it's
only rock and roll or whatever we're
playing
and he it's we might as well have been a
madison square garden dude he's
literally like running
back and forth doing he's doing that
doing being mick jagger
like there's like two camera guys in our
road crew and it's eleven in the morning
and he's like a hundred percent mick
jagger
it's amazing wow
you